good morning believe nation today's
message is free yourself over to your
cart assembler awake mode press the TV
go when I was 50 my wife another nice
hat for a whole afternoon we had a big
pit with fire and I threw everything I
had ever done into that fire this is a
book in thirty eight languages hundreds
and hundreds of articles and DVDs
everything there was and that did two
things one it freed our five kids from
following in the steps of shadow of they
don't know what I do that's just good
and I'm not going to take them someone
says one day all of this will be yours
so the five kids no nothing which is
good the and the second thing is i freed
myself from this anchor of past
achievement or whatever it is and i'm
free to start something new every time
and to decide things from scratch so
what do you think i love this because i
think it's important to free yourself
for a while out of people think of you
and to really date with junior and guy
and what's in your car and not worry
about what they
and three yourself and other stuff and
focus on what
I like I think we all have we all have
these chains that hold us where we are
from the story we tell ourselves or the
beliefs that our parents have the
expectations that our friends have a bus
and the culture that we live in and
you're never going to do anything great
if you don't do the things that make you
[ __ ] a lot agree take some chances break
those chains yeah oh yeah I love it so
the question that they today is what are
some chains that you want to break free
from Jennifer goes deep on that one it
goes deep on that one what are the
chains you need to free yourself from
leave it in the comments below and we'll
join in the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and we'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
a vinspresso free yourself I've done it
over to you or cardell someone similar
sanguine assembler over tehre cargo stem
one somewhere the same thing mr. filming
is a dangerous profession